bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat dimanche dernier les
experts mondiaux du climat le GEC ont
remis un rapport alarmant sur le
réchauffement climatique un rapport qui
souligne notamment la responsabilité des
États pour apporter une réponse il est
encore temps afin d'éviter les risques
les plus sévères liés à l'élévation des
températures c'est dans ce contexte que
la France est lancée dans la transition
énergétique objectif affiché réduire de
50% d'ici 2025 la part de nucléaire dans
notre électricité également réduire de
moitié notre consommation d'énergie
d'ici 2050 donc consommer moins et
consommer plus d'énergie renouvelables
l'été dernier Ségolène Royal la ministre
de l'écologie a présenté les grandes
lignes de cette transition énergétique
en conseil des ministres le Sénat a
également entamé ses travaux ses études
sur le sujet avec de nombreuses
auditions débutaient dès le printemps
aujourd'hui ils additionne des
représentants du Conseil économique
social et environnemental notamment le
président de ce conseil Jean-Paul
Delevoye ainsi que Jean Jouzel
climatologue également membre du GIEC
je suis très heureux avec Hervé Moret
qui va s'exprimer dans un instant
d'accueillir des représentants du
Conseil économique social et
environnemental la personne d'abord de
son président
Jean-Paul Delevoye que nous connaissons
bien les uns des autres
l'ayant rencontré pratiqué dans
différents Sénats
délégation qui est également composée
autour du président de jean-jouzel et de
Laurent César qui ont été les
rapporteurs de du Conseil comique et
social environnemental sur le projet de
loi de transition énergétique quand je
vois d'ailleurs Jean-Paul delvoy ici je
sais qui nous a accueilli souvent dans
le cadre du Conseil national de la
transition énergétique dont je faisais
partie et qui a travaillé depuis plus de
deux ans sur sur ce secteur comme nous
avons des contraintes horaires
à 11h
chacune des deux commissions poursuit
ses travaux donc je vous propose après
que Hervé Moret et lui-même pris la
parole que nous puissions entendre nos
invités
bien merci monsieur le président de la
commission de l'économie chère
Jean-Claude à mon tour je voudrais me
réjouir d'accueillir aujourd'hui le
président du Conseil économique social
et environnemental et les deux
rapporteurs de la vie que vous avez
rendu au mois de juillet sur le projet
de loi relatif à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
madame esard et monsieur jouzelle qui
est par ailleurs je le rappelle parce
que c'est d'actualité vice-président du
GIEC le GIEC qui a publié pas plus tard
que ce week-end un nouveau rapport sur
les perspectives plus qu'inquiétantes en
matière de climat et je ne doute pas que
nous que nous en parlerons ce matin je
voudrais dire quelques mots quand même
sur sur ce projet de loi puisque le
conseil économique social est
environnemental a souligner dans son
rapport que c'était ce projet de loi je
le cite une nouvelle de l'histoire de
l'énergie de la France une étape qui
engage la frange vous cite toujours vers
un nouveau modèle énergétique mais je
crois au-delà que la philosophie de ce
texte nous ont nous allons parler ce
matin et puis tout au long des
prochaines semaines et beaucoup plus
large puisque en fait
il embrasse toutes les questions qui
font de notre modèle de développement
que ce soit en matière de transport en
matière de production en matière de
croissance je crois et le rapport du
GIEC là la clairement montré qu'il n'est
plus seulement à l'ordre du jour de
bouger simplement la répartition du mix
énergétique je crois qu'il faut bien sûr
aller au-delà c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
penser différemment l'imbrication entre
nos modes de production nos modes de vie
nos modes de de comportement dans notre
comportementaux pour la préservation de
notre planète
de sorte à mettre en place un nouveau
modèle de développement dans lequel tout
doit être lié l'énergie que nous
produisons notre façon de consommer
notre manière de nous déplacer de nous
loger de nos chauffer et en quelque
sorte de nous de nous comporter et
finalement cette transition énergétique
sur le Président je crois que vous
l'avez souligné aussi dans le rapport du
Conseil économique social
environnemental c'est un premier volet
mais un volet bien sûr considérable de
ce qu'on appelle la transition
écologique la transition écologique qui
doit nous conduire à passer d'une
économie qui aujourd'hui s'appuie sur
deux facteurs de production on a tous
appris ça dans notre vie étudiante
lointaine le travail et le capital à une
économie qui repose sur trois facteurs
de production le travail le capital
fruit de l'investissement mais aussi ce
qu'on a suffisamment pris en compte
jusqu'à présent
capital naturel c'est-à-dire le capital
que nous n'avons pas créé mais ce
capital sur lequel repose tout
l'équilibre en termes climatique ou en
termes de diversité du vivant je crois
qu'il est
urgent d'intégrer ce capital naturel
dans le fonctionnement de notre économie
et c'est cette approche intégrée qui est
au cœur même de la transition
énergétique et qui permettra de répondre
aux défis très importantes telles que le
réchauffement climatique que nous
évoquons tout à l'heure telle que
l'indépendance énergétique la limitation
des risques environnementaux et bien sûr
la prospérité de nos territoires alors
j'observe que le conseil économique
social environnemental a eu à peu près
la même approche que le Sénat sur la
manière d'aborder ce texte puisque vous
avez confié monsieur le Président à deux
sections du CESE l'examen de ce texte et
au Sénat c'est la solution qui a été
retenue puisqu'il y a une partie des
articles qui sera examinée par la
commission de l'économie et l'autre par
la commission du développement durable
et j'aimerais avant de vous céder la
parole peut-être déjà posé quelques
questions auxquelles je suppose vous
répondrai dans votre intervention
première question vous avez émis de
sérieux doutes sur les moyens financiers
qui sont mis en œuvre pour
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi est-ce
que cette réserves sont susceptibles
d'évoluer au vu des dispositifs qui sont
dans la loi de finance pour 2015
concernant les différents objectifs
chiffrés en termes de part du nucléaire
en termes de gaz à effet de serre ou en
termes d'énergie renouvelable
estimez-vous que les objectifs fixés
sont réalistes accessibles et selon quel
scénario
nous sommes au Sénat que vous connaissez
bien monsieur le Président donc sommes
très attachés à notion de territoire que
penser de la notion de territoire à
énergie positive est-ce que ce concept
qui semble un peu flou peut avoir une
réalité et à quelles conditions
pouvez-vous aussi nous parler d'une
proposition qui est dans votre rapport
mais qui n'a pas été reprise pour
l'instant au Parlement qui la notion de
livret de transition énergétique qui
peut me semble-t-il être très
intéressantes
et puis vous avez reproché au projet de
loi en matière de transport d'être
essentiellement axé sur le tout
électrique comment sortir selon vous de
cette approche enfin dernière question
le rapport du GIEC insiste sur le fait
qu'en matière climatique il y a urgence
à agir mais qu'il est encore temps
d'agir et pensez-vous que ce projet de
loi finalement peut y contribuer et à
quelles conditions voilà monsieur le
Président les quelques questions sur
lesquelles mais il y en a bien d'autres
vous serez certainement interrogé
avant de vous céder la parole j'ajoute
une information donc matérielle comme
l'a dit le président le noir donc nous
avons des réunions de commission à 11h
en ce qui concerne les membres de la
commission du développement durable donc
nous quitterons la salle que nous
laisserons la commission de l'économie
pour nous rendre dans notre salle de
commission qui est la salle 67 donc à
l'issue de l'audition bien merci et
merci Hervé lors du confirme mon membre
de la commission vers l'économique qu'il
conviendrait rester ici pour entendre le
candidat qui nous est proposé au poste
de directeur général de lanrue et donc
nous aurons également nous prononcer à
l'issue de cette audition je voudrais
ajouter à la besace que porte maintenant
le président du Conseil économique
social et environnemental quelques
quelques sujets qui
relèvent plus particulièrement de la
compétence de ma commission
concernant le mix énergétique évidemment
le grand débat porte sur la part cocuppe
le nucléaire dans l'offre en énergie
nous avons observé qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment de consensus au conseil sur
cette question
j'aimerais savoir votre connaître votre
opinion sur la réduction à 50% de la
consommation énergétique finale d'ici à
2050 et d'autre part sur la baisse qui
est programmée de la production
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire à 50%
un autre sujet important d'un point de
vue économique qui tourne autour de la
contribution
au service public de l'électricité là
c'est SPE dont le poids est déjà
important qui pèse sur la vie économique
or il y a évidemment tout un débat
autour de l'élargissement de l'assiette
c'est tellement facile d'aller chercher
des recettes dans une contribution qui
est une sorte d'impôts indirecte pas
tout à fait indolore parce que justement
son poids est en train de s'alourdir
il y a d'ailleurs liés à la CSPE toute
la question de la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique et à cet égard
j'aimerais connaître votre votre opinion
sur
le développement
des technologies
mises en place aujourd'hui chez les
particuliers parce que les industriels
des gens en bénéficient permettant de
mieux contrôler sa consommation c'est
donc tout le développement des réseaux
intelligents du compteur dit
intelligence sur lequel le rapporteur de
la commission des affaires économiques
Ladislas planetowski sera atterrissable
et le président de la commission aussi
puisque nous avons porté tous les deux
un rapport qui avait été fait à l'époque
avant que le gouvernement donne son feu
vert au déploiement qui est
effectivement aujourd'hui des compteurs
dit communicants une question également
sur les ressources dont nous pouvons
disposer
qui sont liés aux hydrocarbures non
conventionnelles
je pense que Laurent César connaît bien
ce sujet pas forcément en particulier
mais je pense que c'est un sujet sur
lequel vous avez eu l'occasion de
travailler et enfin sur les cervicales
d'économie d'énergie bon l'Assemblée
nationale a mis en place un système
est-ce que selon vous c'est un système
qui
peut-être retenu autant de sujets
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
le rapporteur sur lesquels vraiment
votre avis va compter nous en sommes un
début d'examen
c'est la première réunion que nous
tenons avec un invité sur ce sujet
je vous laisse imaginer le nombre de
réunions que nous allons avoir certaines
en commun avec notre notre ami Hervé
Moret mais nous avons voulu consacrer la
place
qu'occupe dans notre réflexion dans
notre travail qu'occupe
le Conseil comics social et
environnemental compte tenu des travaux
importants qui ont été menés et contenu
de la qualité de ses rapporteurs
monsieur le Président
j'ai le plaisir de vous donner la parole
merci Monsieur les présidents chez
Monsieur Lenoir cher Monsieur Moret vous
comprendrez bien que je ferai une
introduction et ensuite laissant le soin
à mes deux rapporteurs Laurent cesar et
Jean zouzel Le bien vouloir vous
restituer les débats qui ont abouti à la
rédaction de cet avis du Conseil
économique social et environnemental et
mais de vous indiquer très clairement
que
ainsi que vous le disiez monsieur Moret
nous avons
très tôt au Conseil économique social
environnemental et bien avant que ce
projet de loi ne soit ne soit engagé
mobiliser la totalité des représentants
de la société civile sur la
problématique de l'énergie nous avons
rendu un avis sur l'efficacité
énergétique sur la transition dans les
transports sur des programmations 2020
2050 nous avons rendu un avis sur la loi
de proclamation ce qui veut dire
simplement que la question que vous
évoquiez nous avons été très orphelins
d'une campagne européenne qui n'a
absolument pas posé le problème de
l'Europe et de l'énergie
nous avons du mal à susciter un débat
politique qui à nos yeux nous paraît
stratégique c'est l'économie et la
productivité l'économie et l'industrie
il est évident que si nous n'avons pas
la maîtrise d'un coup énergétique en
Europe il n'y aura plus d'industrie
énergivore dans 15 ans en Europe c'est
donc un problème syndical lourd c'est un
problème stratégique majeur et l'on voit
bien qu'au moment où là où la
géopolitique du monde est en train de
complètement se bouleversé avec une
croissance durablement faible je suis de
ceux mais c'est une opinion purement
personnelle qui n'est jamais crue ni au
taux de croissance de Monsieur Sarkozy
ni auto de croissance de Monsieur
Hollande je crois que nous sommes plutôt
rentrés dans un taux de croissance fait
pendant quelques années nous sommes en
mutation et en transition et l'on voit
bien que cette problématique de la
croissance faible du coût du pétrole
faible aujourd'hui de la problématique
de la Russie du Moyen-Orient du rapport
du GIEC Jean-Joseph est le mieux placé
pour en parler et qui montre à quel
point aujourd'hui on peut encore essayer
de rester à 2 degrés et que si l'on veut
rester à ce niveau là il y a un vrai
débat à avoir sur l'utilisation des
énergies possible c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait important et en même temps
de l'autre côté je voudrais pas parler à
la place de Jean Josel de montrer
qu'aucun scénarios et d'abordé par le
GIEC ne peut atteindre ses objectifs en
se passant totalement de l'énergie
nucléaire donc ça veut dire qu'il y a
deux limites sur lequel nous devons être
absolument attentifs mais je voudrais
que dans un moment où la société
française est extrêmement
marqué par des rapports violents par
peut-être par un risque de
radicalisation
de grâce c'est un message que je fais
passer de façon générale toutes les
réformes sont imposées comme punitive
anxiogène retrouvons l'enthousiasme de
la transformation l'enthousiasme de la
mutation parce que derrière il y a une
vision la transition énergétique c'est
pas une punition c'est évotement un
enthousiasme vers un mode de vie nouveau
vers un changement nouveau dans lequel
on doit mobiliser de façon positive les
acteurs avec gagnant-gagnant donc
essayons de retrouver en dépassant les
clivages en essayant d'apporter un
apaisement en essayant d'avoir un débat
sur les objectifs et pas sur les
conséquences essayez de ne pas rajouter
une souffrance une souffrance et une
société qui aujourd'hui s'interroge sur
le monde vers lequel nous allons et
comme aujourd'hui la France peut avoir
une formidable leadership mondiale nous
avons perdu la bataille du logiciel nous
pouvons encore gagner la bataille de la
digitalisation industrielle que vous
évoquez et cette digitalisation va
apporter dans la maîtrise de la
précarité énergétique de la maîtrise de
la conduite énergétique dans
l'intelligence des réseaux quelque chose
de tout à fait fondamental il est
absolument incroyable de voir qu'au
moment où la Commission européenne et
sur le point de lancer 300 millions
d'euros sur les infrastructures de voir
que nous n'avons pas une réflexion sur
les connexions sur les surproductions
sur la variabilité climatique selon les
énergies c'est un sujet sur lequel
l'Europe qui doit avoir une capacité de
moraliser la mondialisation par un enjeu
de société dans le cas de la solidarité
prend son compte sur l'épreuve de
rupture de parcours que la modernité la
modélisation continentale de la
production d'énergie de sa connexion de
sa transport et de sa modulation et de
sa régulation ne soit pas porté aussi à
l'échelle du monde c'est un facteur de
stabilité majeur
je crois donc il serait effectivement
intéressant d'avoir tout ce type de
débat combien cela coûte pour agir mais
combien ça coûte pour ne pas agir et et
nous avons rendu au Conseil économique
social et environnemental une
déclaration officielle avant la réunion
des chefs d'État à Bruxelles pour dire
que dans la préparation de la Commission
du COP 21 dans lequel nous sommes très
engagés nous souhaitons que cette
commission que cette déclaration des
chefs d'État soit des contraintes s'il
n'y a pas de contrainte au niveau des
États il n'y aura pas d'engagement au
niveau des acteurs locaux même si nous
avons reçu au CESU les représentants des
régions du du monde du monde entier je
voudrais enfin vous dire que
nous avons
très clairement exprimé
le besoin que tout cela soit cohérent la
France est fatiguée des lois d'affichage
qui ne se retrouvent pas dans les outils
avoir des objectifs c'est important
derrière il faut effectivement la
traduction dans les outils fiscaux dans
les outils financiers et au moment où
vous êtes en train de travailler sur la
réforme territoriale sur la mobilisation
des territoires je crois beaucoup à la
force des territoires et effectivement
cette notion de territoire comment
comment développer par la géostratégie
politique une puissance énergétique à
l'échelle de la planète et comment
mobiliser les acteurs par une proximité
politique permettant d'accompagner et de
pouvoir responsabiliser il est évident
que si nous sommes dans des taux de
croissance faibles les revenus de
retraite de salaire seront faibles la
vraie question c'est comment être avec
moins d'argent et plus heureux ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir maîtriser le reste
à vivre et le reste à vivre ça veut dire
qu'il faudra maîtriser les flux
énergétiques ou électricité etc etc etc
enfin au moment où nous souhaitons la
cohérence entre le territoire et
l'Europe et cette vision géosatrique et
la cohérence entre la loi de finances
les lois de programmation et de la
fiscalité effectivement il y avait deux
dissensus majeurs au sein de cet avis
que nous avons restitué
beaucoup de nos membres ne croyaient pas
ou ne croient pas à la capacité de
baisser la consommation d'énergie de 50%
d'ici 2050 car ça paraît hors d'atteinte
c'est un débat et l'autre débat c'est la
diminution de la part du nucléaire de la
production électrique de 75 à 50 %
effectivement ce débat est très
clairement ouvert au sein de notre
saison je voudrais sans plus tarder
contenu des contraintes horaires mais
aussi de la qualité du travail qui a été
fourni par Jean jauzel et par Laurent
desar leur demander de bien vouloir vous
restituer les propositions que nous
avons faites certaines d'entre elles
d'ailleurs ayant permis de modifier la
loi qui a été présentée à l'Assemblée
nationale et certaines propositions
étant reprises par les parlementaires de
l'Assemblée nationale bien merci le
président donc la parole est agent du
visuel
sur un bouton voilà je voyais bien c'est
gentil merci beaucoup bonjour à tous et
à tout ici
c'est vrai que
je suis remercie c'est vrai que vous
avez
c'est quand même pas que j'en joue seul
et puis dans César qui ont écrit le
rapport il y a quand même beaucoup de
gens et c'est vraiment un gros travail
et il a été très bien aussi accepté au
niveau du Conseil économique et social
voilà donc c'est c'est vrai qu'on tient
à remercier les deux commissions nous
avons travaillé ensemble c'est quand
même différent par rapport à ce pas pour
vous mais nous n'avons pas séparé les
articles c'est un point important c'est
à dire que nous avions effectivement
deux commissions mais nous avons traité
regarder tous les articles ensemble
elles ne vont pas disons
singularisé de certains articles et les
conflits à une des commissions et les
autres à l'autre ça peut être important
je pense dans la démarche alors bon
évidemment vous allez pas échapper donc
vous savez pas échappé à quelques mots
sur sur la conférence de Copenhague très
rapidement d'abord simplement une
précision donc je suis membre du bureau
du GIEC et vice-président de son groupe
scientifique donc ça c'est et donc
j'étais à Copenhague donc l'idée de ce
rapport de synthèse effectivement c'est
de
il n'y a pas d'éléments nouveaux mais
c'est de présenter de façon une
véritable perspective c'est à dire
allant des causes du réchauffement
climatique à l'attribution qu'ils ont
aux activités humaines à ces impacts et
aux solutions à mettre en oeuvre je
crois que c'est aussi tout son maître un
peu côte à côte face à face et problèmes
d'adaptation réchauffement climatique et
se liées à la disons la lutte contre les
émissions des gaz à effet de serre donc
où en sommes-nous le je crois que c'est
très clair diagnostic très clair à
savoir que si on continue sur la
correcteur sur lequel nous sommes nous
risquons d'aller vers 4 degrés en
moyenne à la fin du siècle et ça se
poursuivra par la suite et je dirais
simplement
tous les voyants sont au rouge dans ce
cas là il faut quand même le savoir il
faudra pas nous dire après alors bien
sûr les voyants sont au rouge pour la
fin du siècle pour la deuxième partie du
21e siècle mais c'est quand même la
responsabilité de nos générations alors
les voyants sont au rouge dans tous les
domaines et je dirais simplement que bon
je crois que tout le monde est convaincu
qu'il faut éviter
disons
d'aller vers vers ces zones de 4,5
degrés de réchauffement alors ce qu'il
faut faire tout le monde le sait puisque
tous les pays ont adhéré alors c'est pas
une recommandation du GIEC ne fait pas
de recommandation mais tous les pays de
ces planètes ont adhéré à l'objectif de
mettre en oeuvre des mesures pour
limiter le réchauffement climatique à
long terme à 2 degrés
donc maintenant comment on passe de cet
engagement
à vraiment une action et bien on peut
analyser donc il y a un premier point
qui faut souligner qui est quand même
extrêmement
prégnant à savoir que quand on regarde
l'augmentation de l'effet de serre elle
est pour les trois quarts une année
comme cette année
liée à notre utilisation des
combustibles c'est le deuxième point
important du rapport c'est que
la température de stabilisation à long
terme celle dont on parle dans cet
accord climat c'est-à-dire celles qui
sera discuté à Paris l'an prochain les
deux degrés directement proportionnel à
la quantité cumulée de gaz carbonique
on a émis donc si on veut limiter à
degrés 790 milliards de tonnes de
carbone
on a utilisé les deux tiers donc on a
plus le droit qu'à 250 250 c'est 25 ans
au rythme actuel
250 c'est aussi
20% des réserves moins de 20% des
réserves c'est-à-dire de ce qui est
facilement accessible
qu'on va disons très facilement
accessible je ne parle pas des
ressources c'est deux ou trois pour cent
des ressources de combustibles fossiles
ces réserves il faut savoir et ça
explique quand même mon opposition de
climatologue au gaz de schiste ces
réserves ont doublé
avec depuis 10 ans à travers pétrole non
conventionnel gaz non conventionnel donc
vous voyez bien la position du
climatologue c'est à dire que le
discours il y a le même discours il y a
10 ans était on pourrait utiliser
pratiquement 50% des réserves maintenant
c'est 20%
j'étais à
j'étais à laieu hier il a eu invité à
faire sur la présenter le rapport du
GIEC et c'est vrai qu'on sent bien que
la le secteur fossile n'est pas prêt
mais il faut le faire c'est important
donc alors évidemment on va pas on va
pas falloir 25 ans comme aujourd'hui
dans le meilleur des cas et puis zéro
après ce que conseille les économistes
du geste enfin disons parce que conseil
on fait pas de recommandations mais
parmi les trajectoires possibles c'est
de diviser par deux voire par trois les
émissions à horizon 2050 de continuer
par la suite
comment donc le GIEC effectivement
inclus dans efficacité énergétique pas
de surprise
mais l'accent sur le renouvelable inclut
du nucléaire et du stockage piège du gaz
carbonique et même comme il faut
continuer par la suite après 2050
a pratiquement arrivé à des émissions
nulles toujours si on veut rester en
dessous de degrés mais je répète que
tous les pays ont adhéré à cela il faut
quand même le savoir donc on parle de
beccs c'est à dire en gros vous vous
faites vous prenez une forêt enfin vos
disons faites développer la biomasse
vous utilisez cette biomasse mais avec
stockage des piècesages de gaz carbonix
qui permet effectivement c'est une des
façons de pomper du CO2 de l'atmosphère
donc ça c'est le paysage et donc pour
revenir à votre question oui dans un
contexte tel que celui-là
l'objectif facteur 4 pour la France a
raison 2050 est complètement dans la
ligne de cette perspective de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nous avons
souhaité collectivement au niveau du 16e
remettre cet objectif de façon explicite
je dis il y était de façon implicite est
exacte mais nous avons souhaité qu'il
soit remis lié d'ailleurs dans la loi je
redis simplement que c'est complètement
justifié si vous percez du point de vue
du climat donc je pense que c'est normal
dans un monde où on attend une
diminution par deux voire par trois
raisons 2050 que les pays développés
fassent mieux donc voilà ça c'est un
premier point qui répond donc après je
vais évoquer quelques points donc nous
sommes partagés la tâche avec Laurence
je pense en très bon accord
donc les points que je vais évoquer sont
pas forcément évoqués dans la loi mais
ça mérite de
dire quelques mots alors
parfois il mériterait d'être évoqué donc
sur l'Europe bon disons évidemment les
disons notre notre avis a été a été
mis en place disons a été mis en place
avant les discussions européennes on a
bien noté que les horizons 2030 il y a
cet horizon il y a cette diminution de
moins de 40%, ce qui dépend certains
disent c'est pas assez disons si on y
arriver ce serait déjà pas mal il est
contraignant par contre nous aurions
c'était des disons un accord
contraignant sur l'efficacité
énergétique et peut-être aussi se
renouvelable en tout cas sur
politique européenne cohérente avec la
police s'agit de construire une Europe
forte voilà donc il y a quand même cet
aspect 20%
donc on parlait plutôt en 2020 intègre
un objectif d'efficacité énergétique
également à l'échelon nationale donc ça
c'est aussi important donc ça sera aussi
intéressant de voir ce qu'on fait
horizon 2030 dans cette loi alors il y a
dans la loi il y a 32% d'énergie
renouvelable je pense que c'est toujours
j'ai pas vérifié mais je pense donc
c'est aussi quelque chose d'assez
ambitieux et dont je pense que j'espère
que ça sera préservé
la politique européenne alors là c'est
quand même pour nous elle est bon je
pense moi j'avais participé aussi au
rapport sur transition énergétique avec
Catherine Tissot colle
elle est pas simple de discuter
d'objectif elle devrait être une
véritable politique de l'énergie
ce qui nous manque on est de l'Europe
c'est de façon simple il y a pas de
politique de l'énergie c'est pas
simplement de s'échanger l'électricité
quand il y a de produits un peu produit
trop de produits dans un pays moins dans
l'autre c'est pas ça c'est pas ça une
politique énergétique c'est penser
investissement ces pensées stratégies et
je regrette nous regrettons je pense
qu'il n'y ait pas de véritable stratégie
européenne en termes de l'énergie
donc bon les objectifs européens je
pense que bon je pense que ils sont
endossés maintenant mais ils sont
importants et là aussi il était
important que que disons il soit il soit
vraiment
suivi par nos représentations nationales
et endosser complètement
le dernier point enfin les deux derniers
points sont la recherche évidemment je
suis avant tout un chercheur dans mon
domaine de recherche ce sont plus les
variations passées du climat la
recherche a besoin alors quand on parle
de recherche dans ces domaines je suis
persuadé que beaucoup des
objectifs
ne seront atteints
disons que si on réussit à innover c'est
aussi porteur d'innovation de recherche
de développement je le crois aussi de
recherche fondamentale et c'est ce tissu
qu'il faut mettre en place parce qu'il
n'y ait pas vraiment mais il faut pas
oublier la recherche fondamentales sur
ces aspects énergie mais aussi sur
d'autres aspects beaucoup plus larges
sociétaux et sur des aspects qui qui
dont je pense qu'ils sont très bien
qu'ils apparaissent dans la loi
c'est-à-dire les disons toute l'économie
circulaire disons il est je pense qu'il
est très bien qu'il y a dans ce projet
de loi un chapitre consacré à l'économie
circulaire nous en avons parlé dans
notre rapport et je pense important que
l'économie circulaire face aussi l'objet
vraiment d'une
et c'est pas simplement pour le climat
dans ce cas là c'est pour l'ensemble des
ressources mais on peut élargir le
propos de la nécessaire vigilance de vie
notre environnement à l'ensemble des
ressources
et on avait un peu le regret que dans ce
projet de loi j'en terminerai là et bien
ces aspects économiques circulaires
étaient je dirais limitée aux déchets il
y a beaucoup mieux pas faire dans un
projet de loi où on parle d'économie
circulaire que de simplement parler des
déchets on voit bien pourquoi parce que
il y a des déchets c'est important aussi
mais il y a beaucoup mieux à faire et
beaucoup plus large à faire peut-être
aussi que de que de limiter au déchets
voilà j'en terminerai là merci bien
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
très concise sans faire rebondir le
débat il y a deux points importants que
vous avez soulignés c'est l'Europe
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de politique
européenne dans le domaine de l'énergie
mais en revanche la France et Jean
parler à l'instant avec le président de
le voir doit être le leader des pulls de
politique intelligent dans le domaine de
l'énergie en Europe et puis deuxièmement
la recherche la recherche il est vrai
que si on était en mesure de progresser
notamment pour ce qui est du stockage de
l'énergie
nous aurions résolu bien des problèmes
qui se posent aujourd'hui alors je donne
maintenant la parole à Laurent César
donc dans notre avis un axe nous a guidé
profondément et à rassembler l'ensemble
des conseillers du 16e c'est celui de la
hiérarchisation des objectifs il nous
semble important en effet que pour que
nous puissions atteindre les engagements
qui ont été pris par la France en
matière de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre que l'ensemble des mesures qui
sont proposées dans la loi soyez
archisés il nous semble qu'il y a des
objectifs de court terme qui peuvent
être rapidement mis en oeuvre pour
obtenir des résultats aussi assez
rapides il se trouve que ces résultats
de court terme concernent des secteurs
qui sont les plus énergivores les
bâtiments et le transport et puis il y a
des résultats et des objectifs qui sont
de plus long terme qui vont demander des
travaux collectifs dans la durée qui
vont demander une véritable pédagogie
pour être capable de qualifier notamment
les différents scénarios de mix
énergétiques et qui vont nécessiter donc
plus de temps et je dirais de suivi dans
la durée donc cette hiérarchisation est
nécessite évidemment une très grande
cohérence entre les réglementations
entre les projets de loi une
transparence dans le suivi des décisions
qui sont prises de le des résultats
obtenus et puis je dirais du suivi dans
la durée et nous savons dans le secteur
de l'énergie à quel point le travail et
la prise en compte du long terme est un
facteur important de réussite pour un
pays quel qu'il soit mais la France en a
fait on a bien tiré expérience puisque
nous pouvons dire que nous bénéficions
aujourd'hui de toutes les décisions qui
ont été prises il y a fort longtemps
avant guerre pour ce qui est d'engager
la recherche sur le nucléaire et après
guerre pour ce qui est de d'engager
notamment tous les travaux sur les
grandes infrastructures de production
d'énergie qui existent aujourd'hui qui
nous permettent d'avoir une énergie
qu'on peut qualifier de bon marché
aujourd'hui alors le secteur du bâtiment
est le premier secteur sur lequel des
mesures concrètes sont proposées
nous avons apprécié
cette présentation dans la loi et nous
avons aussi noté que la notion de
performance énergétique du bâtiment qui
apparaît à travers ces mesures est une
notion qui est de nature à mobiliser
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés par la
problématique de l'efficacité
énergétique dans les bâtiments en effet
il nous semble qu'elle peut recevoir un
large consensus que ce soit à partir des
maîtres d'ouvrage des artisans des
lotisseurs bref de toute la profession
concernée par
la construction donc pour le 9 il nous
semble là qu'on a vraiment de la matière
pour provoquer une réelle mobilisation
une réelle dynamique avec évidemment
toute une une un sujet sur la formation
sur les compétences parce qu'on voit
qu'il y a là aussi
des matériaux qu'il faut connaître des
pratiques qu'il faut intégrer pour
proposer au maître d'ouvrage des
solutions qui soient réellement
efficaces en matière d'économie
d'énergie avec des matériaux qui sont
peut-être pas les matériaux de basse
qualité donc on voit que c'est un
travail de d'ensemble qui doit être fait
pour réellement avoir les bâtiments
efficaces en matière de d'énergie dans
la durée le sujet qui est plus compliqué
c'est celui de la rénovation donc
nous sommes
un petit peu interrogatifs surtout
l'accompagnement financier et sur le
réalisme des mesures financières qui
sont proposés pour accompagner tout ce
volet de la mise à niveau si je puis
dire des bâtiments anciens il y a
plusieurs questions que nous avons
notées notamment comment faisons-nous
pour inciter les propriétaires à engager
des travaux de rénovation qui sont
coûteux alors que par ailleurs les
loyers sont plutôt contraints donc on a
un vrai sujet sur la façon dont les
propriétaires qui sont parfois des
personnes pas forcément
très très très
argenté et donc
ne cohérence là encore pour permettre
que ces investissements sur les
bâtiments anciens puissent être faites
avec une incitation qui soit vraiment
efficace nous avons aussi identifié le
problème des personnes qui sont en
difficulté je crois que
ça a été tout à fait prise en compte
dans les travaux au niveau de
l'Assemblée nationale mais il nous
semble important de d'abord
malheureusement souvent les bâtiments
les logements énergivores sont les
logements dans lesquels des personnes en
difficulté sont habites donc il y a deux
sujets à traiter d'une part la façon
dont on aide des personnes qui sont en
difficulté à honorer leurs factures
d'énergie et là on pense que les
propositions qui sont faites en matière
de chaque énergie peuvent régler ce
sujet là mais en aucun cas le chèque
énergie ne répond à la question de
comment on rénove et comment on met en
état si je puis dire les bâtiments c'est
logement énergivores et donc il faut pas
mélanger à notre avis les sujets et le
chèque énergie doit être consacré au
problème de la du paiement de l'énergie
pour les personnes en difficulté mais
c'est d'autres choisir qui doivent être
prises pour travailler si je puis dire
en amont et faire que ces bâtiments
soient ces logements soient des
logements qui permettent de moindre
consommation d'énergie et puis bon on a
aussi bien identifié que
l'accompagnement des personnes en
difficulté ne fait pas l'objet de de
cette loi il y a tout à dispositif avec
les services sociaux tous les acteurs de
proximité qui doivent
être en situation de pouvoir aider ces
personnes à sortir de leur situation
donc on a essayé au ces oeuvres de bien
identifier les sujets et de ne pas faire
un amalgame en pensant que il y avait
une solution miracle qui allait tout
réglé
pour ce qui est du transport deuxième
sujet important pour nous puisque c'est
un secteur qui est également très
consommateur en énergie donc notre
première réaction a été de dire que nous
n'étions pas favorables au tout
électrique dans le domaine du transport
et nous avons je crois été entendu
puisque dans la dernière version que
j'ai eu sous les yeux je crois qu'il y a
eu une ouverture très importante qui a
été faite de façon à pouvoir d'ores et
déjà ne pas
éliminer des solutions qui existent et
qui sont
économes en impact sur l'environnement
je pense notamment aux solutions
hybrides je pense aux solutions qui
utilisent du gaz naturel véhicule ou du
biométhane carburant
et nous avons aussi
proposer que la réflexion permette que
la solution électrique se ré une
solution intéressante dans la durée pour
des usages bien précis et pour ça il
faut continuer à travailler pour que on
est vraiment une bonne vision sur
l'ensemble de la solution électrique
depuis les matériaux qui sont utilisés
pour les batteries le lithium qui est
fourni dans des pays lointains jusqu'à
l'impact sur les réseaux électriques et
puis enfin le retraitement de ces
batteries l'idée étant qu'une très bonne
idée aujourd'hui doit se révéler une
très bonne idée demain et donc il nous
semble important que les travaux
notamment en matière de recherche
continuent à s'opérer pour que cette
solution là sur des usages bien
identifiés puissent se révéler dans le
long terme intéressant mais l'autre
thème que nous avons développé c'est
finalement un travail de
déterminer les solutions adaptées à la
géographie et à l'usage et on voit bien
que pour le grand transport pour
le grand transport ou les les
voyages en dehors de l'urbain il y a
d'autres solutions à prévoir nous avons
aussi considéré qu'il fallait bien sûr
continuer à être dans l'ouverture et
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs dans
les pays étrangers il y a des solutions
très intéressantes qui peuvent aider nos
propres travaux
les carburants deuxième génération par
exemple qui font l'objet de recherche
avancée pour nous aussi sont
intéressants nous avons considéré au 16e
qu'il fallait certainement arrêter les
carburants première génération qui
aujourd'hui ne répondent pas à
nos objectifs de réduction des impacts
sur l'environnement
et d'autre part nous avons aussi
considéré que sur ce sujet là les
pratiques sont en train d'évoluer les
jeunes générations n'ont plus du tout le
même rapport que nous pouvons avoir avec
la voiture on voit toutes les
applications dans les iPhones de
blablacar
etc enfin la SNCF engage aussi une
application pour aller sur le
covoiturage
louer sa voiture à des personnes de
proximité on voit des évolutions fortes
on voit aussi qu'il va falloir
travailler sur les aménagements urbains
pour justement intégrer cette autre
relation au transport et notamment à la
voiture donc
deuxième sujet qui pour nous
comporte des actions de court terme qui
peuvent être immédiatement mis en oeuvre
et puis des travaux à poursuivre pour
travailler là encore sur tous les types
de transport et avoir une vision de
moyens et de long terme un point qui a
attiré aussi notre attention
c'est
toute la gouvernance qui est proposée
sur les plans pluriannuels de l'énergie
les instances qui sont aussi proposés
alors je
n'ai pas dans la tête
le résultat final des travaux après
les discussions à l'Assemblée nationale
mais nous notre leitmotiv c'était d'une
part pour ce qui est des instances la
simplification on a vu apparaître dans
ce le texte que nous avons sur lequel
nous avons travaillé à nombre important
de nouvelles instances certaines ne nous
semblaient pas très bien calé notamment
un comité d'experts dont on avait du mal
à bien comprendre son rôle dans le
dispositif et nous avons aussi
souhaitez une remise à plat du système
existant parce que bon c'est vrai que
c'est un peu mon expérience de
d'exigeante quand on crée quelque chose
de nouveau je pense qu'il est utile
d'expliquer ce qu'on supprime
bon en terme de la simplification des
procédures la simplification des prises
de décision je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important bon qui nécessite un
travail en profondeur mais
qui est absolument nécessaire il nous a
semblé aussi que le la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie donc qui est
prévu sur cinq ans doit concerner toutes
les énergies et je ne cesse de le dire y
compris le pétrole le nucléaire est
concerné le gaz est concerné les
énergies renouvelables sont concernées
je pense et les travaux du GIEC et ce
que j'ai entendu ce matin du président
du GIEC et que Jean nous a rappelé tout
à l'heure montre à l'évidence que toutes
les énergies doivent être travaillées et
donc dans notre rapport nous avons
proposé suggérer que vraiment il y ait
une approche sur l'ensemble des énergies
et non pas
concentré uniquement sur le problème
énergie renouvelable et nucléaire sur ce
sujet là nous avons apprécié que des
mesures soient prises pour le nucléaire
en exploitation
qui est un vrai sujet à part entière et
tout ce qui consiste à améliorer
l'information la transparence
et le rôle de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire à particulièrement été soutenu
par les conseillers du 16e donc sur ce
point là nous nous n'avons pas eu de
remarques dissonantes nous avons bien
différencié le nucléaire de demain
considérant et c'est là que dans notre
assemblée il y a un dissensus avec des
personnes qui pensent que le scénario
proposé est irréaliste et d'autres qui
pensent qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin ce qui était intéressant dans les
travaux que nous avons menés c'est que
nous avons réussi à sortir de ce
dogmatisme dont nous avons l'habitude
pour dire nous croyons suffisamment à
l'importance des objectifs globaux sur
les réductions des gaz à effet de serre
pour tenter de poser des pierres sur ce
chemin là et avancer en mettant un petit
peu de côté nos dogmatismes et c'est
ainsi que notre recommandation est de
continuer le travail sur les scénarios
de mix énergétique qui de notre avis ne
sont pas terminés de façon à pouvoir les
éclairer complètement sur les impacts en
matière
de coûts en matière d'impact
environnemental nous mettent-ils ou pas
dans le bon sens pour aller vers la
réussite des objectifs de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre
quels sont les risques de chacun de ces
scénarios et quel est l'impact sur la
facture du consommateur donc ils nous
semble que si nous voulons vraiment
aller dans cette volonté d'une
transition la transition on a beaucoup
insisté pour que ce mot-là soit conservé
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que nous on
était on avait repris le titre du
document qui nous avait été proposé on
avait nouveau modèle énergétique mais
notre premier propos à Ségolène Royal a
été de lui dire madame la ministre nous
souhaitons nous que votre projet de loi
soit toujours reprennent bien le thème
de la transition énergétique parce qu'il
s'agit bien de créer une mobilisation
collective et positive pour passer d'une
situation telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
à une autre que nous ne connaissons pas
et qu'il nous faut construire ensemble
il y a un thème sur la pédagogie sur la
façon dont on travaille ensemble pour
créer les conditions de choix éclairées
et qui réellement permet au niveau local
parce que je pense que il y a beaucoup
de décisions qui sont du ressort presque
de l'individu de mon choix à moi en tant
que consommateur
au niveau des intercommunalités et au
niveau de la région dans une cohérence
avec un programme national donc d'où
notre souhait là aussi de la cohérence
entre les évolutions de l'organisation
territoriale et les évolutions en
matière de de transition énergétique
avec une claire
identification des marges de manœuvre
qui seront possibles et nécessaires à
chacun de ces niveaux de notre
organisation territoriale de
voilà merci de votre attention merci
merci Laurence pour cette exposition
extrêmement riche alors nous sommes
entendus avec Hervé pour donner la
parole alternativement représentant de
la Commission à faire d'économies qui
nous allons commencer par les
rapporteurs et de la commission du
développement durable et ensuite les
membres des deux commissions se
manifeste auprès des présidents
respectifs pour signaler leur
souhait d'intervenir je voudrais
simplement ajouter un point important tu
pas sûr qu'on est vraiment évoqué
quel va être la demande en énergie d'ici
à 2030 2040 2050
c'est fondamental
je veux pas engager plus avant le débat
mais c'est un sujet qui déjà divise
parce que l'offre doit notamment pour
l'électricité correspondent exactement à
la demande
oui parce que l'économie numérique va
consommer et ben voilà c'est avec
l'économie numérique et les transports
et les transports notamment le véhicule
et écrits si vous voulez Hervé un petit
bout non juste un mot d'abord pour dire
qu'en si l'on sert la commission du
développement durable nous n'avons pas
encore nommé notre rapporteur puisque
nous devons le faire à l'issue de cette
réunion donc je donnerai la parole à un
candidat au poste de rapporteur sur ce
projet de loi je ne dis pas pour les
membres de la commission qu'il ne
s'étonne pas de voir un rapporteur
s'exprimer alors que nous n'avons pas
nommé c'est un prêt rapporteur appelons
ça comme on le veut simplement je vais
pas non plus rebondir sur tout ce qui a
été dit parce que beaucoup de choses ont
été dites d'une grande qualité je crois
que nous avons tous beaucoup appris ce
matin moi j'aimerais juste relever deux
choses qui m'ont paru particulièrement
importantes d'abord c'est la l'optimisme
du président de le voir je crois qu'il a
raison on est dans un pays où la réforme
est forcément aujourd'hui perçu comme
négative forcément anxiogène en ce
domaine commandant autre et je crois
qu'il faut que sur ce texte comme sur
d'autres on arrive à positiver les
choses et effectivement à montrer que la
réforme sur son arrivera jamais rien
dans ce pays la réforme elle peut aussi
symboliser l'espoir et une nouvelle voix
et un nouveau chemin et quand vous
disiez ce président tout à l'heure que
on avait toujours tendance à regarder
combien ça coûte d'agir sans voir
combien ça coûte si on n'agit pas ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qui est
important et je crois qu'il faut que que
l'on regarde davantage quand on met de
l'argent sur un projet quel qu'il soit
un dossier quel qu'il soit en ayant
comme on le fait quand on est et ça
m'est arrivé dans ma vie les chefs
d'entreprise en ayant une colonne
dépense et une colonne retour
c'est-à-dire en fait apprécier les
choses en termes d'investissement et pas
en termes de de dépenses pure et dure
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
quand l'argent est rare
le rapporteur le disait pour les ménages
mais c'est vrai aussi pour nos
collectivités c'est vrai que ça n'est
pas facile aujourd'hui de devoir mettre
de l'argent sur des projets de aussi
important que cela ou d'autres mais il
faut vraiment avoir cette approche je
crois en terme en terme d'investissement
et pas et pas de dépenses voilà donc on
peut se le président de la parole
au sens où lui a été désigné on va
commencer par celui qui est désigné que
la dislas merci monsieur le Président
oui je vais essayer d'être pas trop long
pour laisser la parole mais collègues
simplement d'abord
au président de le voir je voudrais te
dire Jean-Paul merci d'avoir bien placé
ce texte dans un contexte économique qui
est celui que nous connaissons que sur
le contexte français européen et mondial
qui va connaître durablement un taux de
croissance faible et merci d'avoir
appelé et tu auras peut-être deux trois
autres choses je me suis délecté en
t'entendant est-ce que je peux poser
cinq questions précises la première
monsieur le Président vous l'avez
rappelé certains membres du conseil ont
exprimé un certain nombre de réserves
sur la part du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique j'aurais aimé savoir
quelles étaient ces réserves
et j'aurais aimé savoir parce que je bon
j'ai eu le temps de regarder un tout
petit peu je crois qu'il y a eu même des
réserves sur et des interrogations sur
la constitutionnalité du plafonnement
proposé de la production nucléaire à sa
capacité actuelle pouvez-vous me
confirmer et oui lesquels deuxième
question la CSPE qu'a évoqué le
président le noir
vous aviez vous
souhaitez vous aviez pris que disait une
amélioration de la lisibilité et la
transparence du fonctionnement de la
CSPE on sait tout que c'est un truc
monstrueux qui ne cesse de grandir et
qui supporter par les citoyens ou les
entreprises dans leur facture
d'électricité
et puis vous avez eu le temps
d'apprécier la proposition qui est dans
la le texte de loi de créer un comité de
gestion de la CSPE est-ce que vous êtes
allé plus loin dans les travaux que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure est-ce que vous
êtes allé plus loin sur cette mise à
plat de la sieste sur un élargissement
de la sienne sur
faire appel à d'autres énergies
éventuellement pour payer cette facture
importante troisième question
et là je sais que vous êtes allé plus
loin mais vous ne l'avez pas tellement
évoqué dans votre dans votre texte et
c'est normal que le président le noir y
est fait allusion parce qu'il a beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus avec son collègue
député bataille les hydrocarbures non
conventionnels bon on ne peut pas y
faire abstraction je voudrais savoir si
le conseiller économique et social c'est
prononcé sur l'opportunité de savoir ce
qu'il y a dans notre sous-sol je parle
pas encore de l'exploitation je parle de
l'exploration chercher à savoir
ou jusqu'où vous êtes avez-vous effectué
des recherches je sais que ça n'est pas
dans le rapport sur cette Lalou cette
sur la transition mais je sais que vous
avez fait des recherches là-dessus
quatrième question
le système des certificats d'économie
d'énergie
vous avez souhaité que ce soit
simplifié est-ce que le dispositif les
députés ont fait un bon travail
puisqu'ils ont amélioré et ils ont même
inventé puisque c'était pas prévu
initialement dans la loi est-ce que le
système adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez eu le temps de voir si ça va
dans le sens que vous souhaitiez ou non
parce que j'ai cru comprendre que vous
aviez eu largement le temps d'examiner
le texte initialement mais bien sûr vous
n'avez pas eu le temps de voir
d'examiner les travaux des de nos
collègues parlementaires de l'Assemblée
nationale et enfin dernière dernier
sujet je reste sur la part chers
collègues concernant la commission des
affaires économiques
l'article 7 bis du projet de loi prévoit
pour les consommateurs bénéficiant du
tarif social d'électricité du gaz une
une mise à disposition et surtout un
affichage en temps réel bon je suis
personnellement très réticent à ça je
pense que chercher quasiment impossible
je pense que ça va être des dépenses
coûteuses et je pense que nous serons
nous ne serons pas bien utilisés là
aussi avec vous travaillez avec vous
réfléchi avez-vous préconisé certaines
mesures merci Monsieur président bien
merci monsieur le rapporteur et puis on
va donner peut-être la parole tout de
suite à Luna et je propose ensuite que
une réponse globale est-ce que ce qu'on
fait une réponse spécifique au
rapporteur c'est mieux et après on fait
comme ça donc monsieur le presque
rapporteur vinaigre c'est ça rapporteur
pressenti c'est un truc bizarre mais bon
ça existe la preuve donc merci président
de le voir merci au rapporteur merci à
nos présidents de nous retrouver ici
avec un travail je dirais avec mon
collègue rapporteur de la commission des
affaires économiques qui a été en partie
mâché je dirais par le CESU et donc
merci pour la qualité de ce qui a été
fait à ce niveau là alors quant à moi
vous parlez de pédagogie je crois juste
raison la première remarque que je ferai
c'est que il s'agit d'une véritable
révolution culturelle
c'est quelque chose qui touche
profondément et il va falloir de la
pédagogie si on veut obtenir les
résultats que nous recherchons
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de loi
d'affichage pour avoir été rapporteur du
Grenelle 2 de l'environnement j'ai
encore souvenir les objectifs quand
c'était fixés qui ont été votés à la
quasi-unanimité et que nous n'avons
jamais atteint parce que nous n'avons
pas mis les mesures qu'il fallait mettre
en face donc Monsieur Joseph vous sonnez
le toxin vous dites les voyants sont au
rouge
c'est vrai vraisemblablement vrai bon
quels sont les mesures que nous prenons
concrètement pour faire en sorte que
nous puissions atteindre les objectifs
qui sont vous l'avez dit et répétés et
je souhaite que ça soit un élément
important je n'en suis pas persuadé que
ça soit dans tous les esprits les 2%
sont validés par tous les états
on annonce ça à nos concitoyens les
États ont dit et je retourne dans mon
Grenelle 2 nous avons dit que et nous
n'avons pas les résultats à l'arrivée
parce que nous n'avons pas pris les
mesures si la première chose qu'on
pourrait la première question que je
pourrais poser est une question très
basique on veut faire quelque chose mais
avec quel argent
et je trouve je trouve que dans ce texte
il y a un manque de précision évident si
nous n'avons pas les moyens à mettre en
face ce que nous préconisons nous
n'arriverons pas à atteindre l'objectif
donc première question quel est selon
vous les financements possibles pour
atteindre les objectifs que nous nous
donnons dans ce texte
deuxièmement est-ce que ce texte selon
vous est à la hauteur de l'enjeu et je
rajouterais quels sont les angles morts
si vous permettez ce terme qui n'y
figure pas
troisièmement pour rester dans mon
domaine et aller très rapidement sur la
mobilité qui représente 26% de gaz à
effet de serre c'est quelque chose de
d'important vous avez dit le véhicule
électrique qui est insuffisant
et le seul objectif chiffré que l'on
trouve dans ce texte c'est 7 millions de
bornes de recharge alors qu'on est à
8000 ayant été l'auteur du Livre vert
sur les véhicules électriques j'entends
bien votre remarque mais c'est un début
et il faut continuer parce que du
véhicule électrique on passera
vraisemblablement à l'hydrogène et ça
sera une avancée considérable
considérable pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens dont je rappelle que
aujourd'hui la nuisance numéro 1 pour
les urbains c'est le bruit avec un
véhicule électrique vous n'avez plus de
bruit la nuisance numéro 2 c'est la
santé la pollution vous avez annoncé
42000 morts prématurés en France vous ne
les avez plus non plus donc le véhicule
électrique c'est insuffisant je suis
d'accord pour que on ouvre effectivement
sur l'ensemble des énergies et vous
propositions me paraissent aller dans le
bon sens je dirais est-ce que vous
pouvez être plus un peu plus précis pour
intégrer à la fois cette mobilité
électrique et atteindre là encore les
objectifs qu'on s'était fixés et puis
finalement une dernière question
j'ai pas le temps je pense d'évoquer
l'économie circulaire où là encore
est-ce qu'on est assez à la fois
réaliste et ambitieux dans cette
économie circulaire que tout le monde
appelle de nos vœux que tout le monde
appelle le neveu mais je terminerai sur
la qualité de l'air donc
l'option qui est retenue par la France
est-elle compatible avec les objectifs
de l'Europe première question et
deuxièmement une remarque hier j'avais
l'occasion
de déjeuner avec le président
de Peugeot PSA et il nous a dit quelque
chose qui m'a beaucoup impressionné il
nous a dit que les normes que préparer
la Chine qui est très en retard les
normes que prépare la Chine pour 2020 en
pollution de l'air seront beaucoup plus
difficiles à atteindre que les nôtres
c'est à dire que l'industrie chinoise
est en train de se mettre un ordre de
bataille pourra avoir des normes de
demain matin pas aujourd'hui mais de
demain matin qui seront plus sévères que
les nôtres qu'en pensez-vous et que
peut-on faire à notre niveau
bien écoutez je propose que
nos deux rapporteurs du Conseil
communique social environnemental
répondent à ces différentes
interventions
vous voulez reprendre votre respiration
et juste après comme je l'ai dit
non mais nous avons entendu des propos
extrêmement intéressants écoutez comme
d'habitude on donne d'abord la parole
pour une réponse au rapporteur et
ensuite bien sûr et j'ai noté déjà sa
sombre de demande d'intervention je n'ai
pas noté celle de Martial Bourquin
c'est une recommandation qui est déjà
entendu par ceux qui vont intervenir
alors Laurence alors je vais essayer de
faire vite
donc la part du dans le mix énergétique
bon c'est vrai dans notre assemblée il y
a
un de deux
visions
certains qui trouvent que la part du
nucléaire doit être la plus basse
possible et que ce qui est prévu est
encore beaucoup trop important et
d'autres qui disent que c'est
complètement irréaliste et qu'on ne
pourra pas atteindre les objectifs
d'impact de
environnementaux si on ne garde pas une
part importante enfin une part je vais
pas la qualifier dans les scénarios de
mix énergétique mais je vous disais tout
à l'heure on a voulu essayer de sortir
de ça en disant d'abord il faut qu'on
soit en relation avec l'évolution de la
de la croissance ou pas
de consommation d'électricité notamment
de façon à avoir des chiffres à partir
de quel on puisse réellement travailler
et deuxièmement
créer des mettre en place des objectifs
très concrets pour diminuer rapidement
l'appel à des énergies qui ont un impact
en carbone important donc il nous a
semblé là aussi qu'il fallait commencer
par une approche pragmatique concrète
de façon à pouvoir après qualifier d'une
façon organisée et réaliste la
diminution ou pas du nucléaire à quelle
échéance selon quel modalités alors nous
n'avons pas travaillé sur la
constitutionnalité
un des conseillers a mis en avant ce
sujet là mais nous-même nous n'avons pas
travaillé je crois que le Conseil d'État
a dû
doit traiter cette question il me semble
sur la CSPE alors là c'est un sujet qui
nous a beaucoup intéressé nous trouvons
que l'instance qui est proposée pour
avoir de la transparence du suivi du
contrôle est absolument nécessaire nous
considérons que il est tout à fait
prématuré d'élargir l'assiette de cette
de cette CSPE
considérant que le principe de base
c'est que chaque énergie doit supporter
ces externalités donc si on veut avoir
une vraie transparence et une vraie
compréhension du coût de chacune des
énergies
essayons d'aller dans cet objectif là et
ne
utilisons pas la CSPE comme le
fourre-tout là aussi qui va régler tout
on a un urgent besoin de comprendre et
de connaître le coût de chacune des
énergies de façon à pouvoir là aussi
faire des le choix dans la durée donc
l'organe l'instance créée nous semble
importantes pour nous donner de la de la
visibilité sur l'utilisation de cette de
cette CSPE est-ce qu'elle répond aux
objectifs qui ont été fixés et d'autre
part
évitons de faire porter par les
consommateurs d'une énergie le poids
d'une autre énergie ça ne pourrait
aboutir qu'à un brouillage qui ne nous
semble pas du tout aller dans le sens
d'une bonne compréhension
des choix à faire pour demain
je pourrais y revenir et j'ai
éventuellement un petit papier que je
pourrais vous remettre si ça peut vous
intéresser voilà
sur les hydrocarbures non conventionnels
nous n'avons pas nous à l'occasion de
cet avis et à travailler sur le sujet
donc je pas donner mon avis personnel
qui n'a pas franchement d'intérêt
sur les certificats d'économie d'énergie
alors je devais je ne nous avons
souhaité donc qu'il soit simplifié
et qu'il soit évalué et surtout qu'il y
ait une meilleure gouvernance qui puisse
intégrer les acteurs représentatifs donc
on a là encore demandé un dispositif qui
permette une meilleure lisibilité et
pour une plus grande efficacité je sais
pas si tu veux rajouter quelque chose au
dessus
et puis alors l'affichage en temps réel
de la console alors là c'est un sujet
que je connais un petit peu c'est ce que
je me suis occupée à l'époque des
conteurs communicants pour le gaz et
nous avions fait et nous travaillons la
main dans la main avec les électriciens
sur ce projet là et nous avions fait des
tables rondes dans les expérimentations
avec des clients des clients de tout
ordre particulier ou pas et
globalement l'affichage en temps réel ne
leur apportait pas grand chose donc par
contre ce qu'ils ont trouvé comme étant
vraiment un plus et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il y a d'autres fluides qui le font
sur les factures c'est quand on voit les
évolutions des consommations sur des
voilà sur un an deux ans et trois et on
voit la saisonnalité et voilà ça c'est
pour ceux qui s'intéressent réellement à
mieux comprendre la façon dont on
consomme ça ça a été un plus alors je ne
dis pas que demain ou après-demain avec
l'évolution des techniques modernes ça
sera pas quelque chose qui qui devra
être déployé mais dans un premier temps
ça n'est pas ce qui est remonté des
tables rondes que nous avions faites à
l'époque sur ce sujet là alors il peut y
avoir après sur des
usages ou des process particulier des
besoins chez les mais je pense que ça
déjà les personnes qui ont des process
de production très consommateurs
d'énergie on doit avoir ce qu'il faut
pour piloter leur consommation
alors bon là la pédagogie bon je pense
que oui enfin je me permets de dire que
pour moi et pour le 16h on a tous bien
intégré et le travail que nous avons
fait dans un temps très court le texte
on l'a eu il avait trois semaines pour
produire notre avis donc on avait devant
nous un 80 conseillers des plus écolos
j'allais dire au plus nucléocrates et il
fallait quand trois semaines on arrive à
commettre un avis et nous nous étions
engagés Jean et moi à ce que ça soit pas
la liste des dissensus sinon on se dit
qu'on apporterait rien aux travaux donc
on s'est fixé l'objectif de sortir avec
un avis qui serait peut-être modeste
mais où il y aurait vraiment une volonté
collective d'avancer et on a fait le
l'expérience que pendant ce travail
assez intense qui qui s'est passé et
bien il y a eu de la pédagogie on s'est
écouté on a pu apporter des éléments de
compréhension mettre en perspective et
vraiment ça vaut le coup ça prend du
temps mais ça doit se faire à mon avis
au local partout sur le terrain parce
que c'est un sujet sur lequel il y a
beaucoup d'idées reçues qui circulent on
n'y connaît pas grand chose c'est
compliqué alors certains vont dire en
plus à certaines entreprises qui sont
plutôt opaques je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas je pense que c'est vraiment un
sujet qui est de l'ordre de l'intérêt du
citoyen et si on veut prendre des
décisions de moyens et long terme qui
soit réellement éclairé et bien c'est
nécessaire je suis un peu enthousiaste
là dessus enfin mais je pense que il y a
pas d'autre solution
l'économie circulaire je vais peut-être
te laisser
et puis la qualité de l'air je te laisse
qu'il faut
mais bon ça fait quand même 30 ans qu'on
répète les mêmes choses du point de vue
climat on peut continuer à faire de la
pédagogie mais à un moment il faut agir
je vais être très clair donc un moment
bon
pensez bien gentil mais
donc oui on essaye d'en faire bien sûr
quel argent alors moi c'est vrai que
c'est pour moi dans les angles morts
c'est probablement l'aspect financier de
la loi qui est peut-être le plus faible
je rappelle une chose que je n'ai pas
dites mais qui est important dans ce
contexte parce que notre conseil a
réaffirmé que la transition énergétique
requiert qu'un prix suffisamment
incitatif ça ne va au carbone si on ne
donne pas de prix au carbone rien ne se
passera il faut des instruments
économique des leviers fiscaux quand on
voit le rapport le second rapport Stern
qui est bon 600 milliards de de au
niveau mondial de subside au
combustibles fossiles et 400 milliards
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique on se pose des questions
quand même sur une scène dans lequel on
vit il faut quand même le savoir sont
des chiffres qui sont sur la place
publique donc on peut les contester on
peut en discuter mais ils sont là donc
ça je parle bien au niveau mondial donc
effectivement
l'angle mort c'est peut-être l'argent
moi j'aurais aimé je le redis j'étais
très impliqué dans le droit de
l'environnement d'où est né cette idée
de contribution climat énergie je suis
breton mais je regrette que l'écotaxe
n'est pas été mise en oeuvre on aurait
pu en discuter mais je le dis
franchement même en étant breton et je
le dis aussi en Bretagne donc c'est pas
le problème non mais un moment si si
effectivement il faut des moyens
financiers et des leviers fiscaux quand
me dit ça donc angle mort je pense que
c'est cela qui fera la une difficulté
pour la loi sa mise en oeuvre
consommation d'énergie je me suis aussi
beaucoup appliqué dans le débat national
sur le transition énergétique j'étais
membre des comité de pilotage il y a
quand même beaucoup de travail de
beaucoup de travaux de faits sur oui
bien sûr qu'il faut diminuer notre
consommation énergétique en France à
horizon 2050 tous les scénarios le
disent
et quand même c'est un bénéfice
n'oubliez pas que ce 70 milliards
d'importations chaque année pratiquement
le déficit donc quel est le mal à
diminuer nos importations de combustible
fossiles il faudra qu'on nous le dise
oui c'est bien alors les scénarios c'est
quoi il y a ceux qui vont de moins de 20
% effectivement de il y a tout un
ensemble scénarios je vous invite à les
regarder mais ça existe le débat
national soit transition énergétique
tous les scénarios ont été examinés tous
les scénarios montrent une diminution de
la consommation d'énergie les moins
ambitieux de 20% les plus ambitieux
effectivement de 50% effectivement et
c'est passé dans un objectif de la loi
c'est plus une conséquence du double
objectif de division par 4 et de
diminuer la diminution de la part du
nucléaire qui amène de façon
effectivement à une diminution de 50%.
voilà sur ce point la qualité de l'air
et la Chine oui j'étais aussi à laïeul
en dernier la fin la guerre la disons
l'ambition chinoise est très claire a
été réaffirmée à cette la différence à
laquelle j'étais bien sûr que les
Chinois ont compris parce que leur vrai
problème c'est le charbon et il faut
aussi qu'on il faut aussi qu'on
comprenne que que effectivement la
pollution et on peut pas revenir sur sur
ces aspects pollution doivent être
traités ils sont quand même assez
à ses proches de ce qu'on traite il y a
pas non plus beaucoup de pollution si on
utilise le gaz donc on peut aussi dire
ça il y a moins de pollutions qui sont
utilisées je pars c'est pas ce débat
mais il doit être à l'esprit et je veux
dire une chose que je dis souvent
cette transition elle est inexorable
j'ai pôle Vergès en face moi Paul sait
qui on va devoir s'adapter au
réchauffement climatique
donc il faut pas jouer avec ça ne dites
pas dans on sera plus là mais ne dites
pas on ne savait pas c'est clair il faut
pas jouer avec ça et c'est clair qu'il
faut changer de mode de développement
pour moi je le dis et on va devoir
s'adapter réchauffement climatique de
toute façon il faut penser à cela et
mais je redis que si on ne fait rien on
va vraiment vers des zones où ça sera
très très difficile de s'adapter voilà
donc ce sont des des points clairs qu'on
moi je me suis aussi impliqué dans je
dis ça parce que c'est un autre rapport
du césa sur la natation réchauffement
climatique que j'évoque ici pas celui
pas celui dont on parle aujourd'hui donc
voilà donc moi je pense qu'il faut de
l'ambition alors je redis dans dans la
loi l'ambition y est dans les objectifs
je pense maintenant la loi elle sera
jugée à sa capacité à être mise en
oeuvre et voilà c'est tout je le dis je
le redis y compris à la radio quand on
m'interroge la force de la loi la loi
est ambitieuse dans ses objectifs pour
moi elle est tout à fait en ligne avec
les objectifs climat après c'est sa mise
en oeuvre sur laquelle on jugera de ça
effectivement de sa capacité de la
capacité de pays à la mettre en œuvre
bien merci monsieur je vous aide alors
contenu des arrêts de jeu on va
prolonger un peu en accord avec des
personnes à l'extérieur donc 15 minutes
de plus
alors on va alterner des prises de
parole Roland Courtot pour les affaires
économiques
si monsieur le Président oui mais tout a
été dit ou presque
je dois donc éliminer une série de
questions puisque nous avons déjà eu une
réponse je voudrais revenir sur les
propos de Monsieur le Président
vous avez dit les mesures ne peuvent pas
être punitives il faut que l'on se
retrouve dans l'enthousiasme vous avez
dit quelque chose comme cela je crois
que en effet que pour réussir la
transition il faudra évidemment des
moyens on vient d'en parler mais je
crois également que
au-delà des principales dispositions du
texte c'est-à-dire l'efficacité
énergétique le développement des
énergies renouvelables les mesures
spécifiques au transport etc etc pour
réussir la transition il va falloir non
pas entrer dans une logique répressive
mais plutôt mettre en oeuvre une
véritable politique de la pédagogie et
j'allais dire d'accompagnement
si nous voulons révolutionner les
comportements je crois qu'il va falloir
recueillir d'abord l'adhésion de nos
populations et du plus grand nom mais
pour cela rappelez peut-être que la
transition énergétique représente un
levier de sortie de crise peut-être le
plus efficace c'est peut-être le plus
rapide mais aussi peut-être le moteur du
renouveau industriel et puisque j'ai
évoqué l'indispensable mobilisation des
populations pour réussir la transition
j'ajouterai que pour mobiliser le plus
grand nombre il nous faudra aussi mettre
de l'humain dans ce débat
en faisant référence par exemple à
l'équité à la justice à la lutte contre
la précarité et à la solidarité de tous
sur une planète unique j'ai parlé
précarité énergétique moi je me réjouis
de la mise en oeuvre de du chèque
énergie
certes le nombre des bénéficiaires des
tarifs sociaux c'est à dire tarifs de
première nécessité établi spécial de
solidarité pour le gaz ont été ouverts à
quelque chose comme 4 millions de de
ménages c'est un grand grand pas en
avant mais force était de constater que
cela concernait ce qui se chauffait à
l'électricité et au gaz par contre nous
avons oublié au bord du chemin celles et
ceux qui se chauffent au fioul et au
bois et là je crois que il était
indispensable que le chèque énergie
prenne en compte les situations de ces
personnes la biocarburant je vais très
vite d'accord pour laisser de côté les
biocarbures en première génération
mais alors mais alors il va falloir
mettre le paquet sur la deuxième
génération je parle de la ligne au
cellulose et il va falloir mettre un
sacré paquet sur la recherche de la
troisième sur la troisième génération
c'est à dire les micro-algues une
question qui n'a pas été posée et que
pensez-vous du développement de
l'auto-consommation en matière
d'électricité d'origine renouvelable et
enfin et enfin j'en terminale dessus
concernant les mesures en direction des
transports 26% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre on ne peut pas dire que
ces mesures-là dans le texte du projet
de loi se résume toute électrique j'ai
là la liste des mesures qui concernent
les mesures à prendre donc
concernant le secteur des transports je
pense que cette liste est assez
impressionnante nous sommes loin de nous
concentrer uniquement sur le tout
électrique
merci donc je vais donner la parole à un
membre de la commission Développement
Durable j'ai demandé quand même aux
personnes qui s'expriment d'être brève
parce que même si on a rajouté un petit
peu de temps il y a beaucoup de demandes
de parole et donc soyez bref madame
Herviaux à la parole
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
très rapidement non seulement mes
félicitations pour le travail accompli
mais également mes remerciements de
rapporteurs et monsieur le Président
pour la clarté de leur propos et l'aide
qu'ils apportent à notre travail de
parlementaire
comme disait mon collègue beaucoup de
choses ont été dites donc je vais me
recentrer très vite sur deux choses tout
d'abord c'est vrai que l'urgence
climatique est là elle fera pas notre
porte depuis longtemps comme vous le
disait Monsieur Joseph et c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin d'aller très vite
maintenant il ne faut pas oublier tout
ce qui touche aussi très souvent lié à
la pollution notamment atmosphérique au
problème de santé je pense qu'il faudra
insister là-dessus le deuxième point sur
lequel je voudrais insister c'est
lorsque vous disiez tout à l'heure les
les vous parliez des territoires
énergies positives moi je suis tout à
fait
persuadé que c'est de là aussi que
viendra à la fois la pédagogie mais
aussi les l'exemplarité et le
développement de l'ensemble du
sur la simplification administrative la
future loi notre sur les territoires les
les
urgences qu'il y a à avoir les énergies
renouvelables et puis ça ne prend pas
parce que il y a toujours un tas de
barrières de choses qui font que on
reporte etc et je voyais dans votre
rapport vous faisiez allusion à je crois
que c'est la page 15 ou 16 ou 17 je sais
plus à la nécessité aussi de donner
comme vous le disiez monsieur le
Président cette volonté et cette
enthousiasme des populations en faisant
en sorte que sur ces petits territoires
il soit aussi partie prenante et même
financièrement pour aller jusqu'à se
dire on prend notre destin en main et on
va vers un territoire à énergie positive
on arrêterait la bien merci Yannick
vogrenard
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
d'avoir ajouté un quart d'heure à la
discussion néanmoins je suis convaincu
qu'il y aura probablement beaucoup de
frustration et c'est normal et je sais
pas comment il pouvait en être autrement
du coup monsieur le Président on va
avoir beaucoup d'autres auditions avant
de discuter finalement de ce projet de
loi je m'interroge sur le fait de
l'intérêt qui aurait auditionné à
nouveau le président du 16h en
particulier à la fin de l'ensemble de
nos auditions avant que nous ayons à en
débattre en séance plénière ça me semble
intéressant parce que ça permet d'avoir
des avis de la société civile qui ne
sont pas des positionnement tactiques
qui peuvent exister ici ou là nous ne
savons bien nous ça me semblerait
intéressant enfin moi je reprenais en
tout cas de nouvelles auditions à la fin
des auditions
le débat qui qui nous préoccupe
aujourd'hui est un débat bien sûr
politique majeur pour nous-mêmes et pour
les générations futures on mesure bien
les difficultés qu'il y a entre
l'affichage politique on l'a vu au
niveau du Grenelle de l'environnement et
la réalité ensuite la mise en œuvre du
politique qui ont été affichées et c'est
un problème selon moi crucial de notre
vie démocratique également vous l'avez
dit de le voir c'est un problème
européen l'évidence c'est aussi un
problème international bien entendu à
partir du moment au niveau européen
aujourd'hui on n'avance pas sur le plein
énergétique pas plus que l'on avance sur
une Europe de la défense on mesure bien
les difficultés qu'il pourrait y avoir
concrètement objectivement à mettre en
place une politique énergétique
européenne du coup ça nous amène à
discuter automatiquement d'un autre
problème politique au niveau de l'Europe
ce que certains ont dirigé en cercle
concentrique c'est-à-dire une Europe à
27 aujourd'hui ne peut pas avoir
l'ambition sur des thèmes majeurs
d'avancer en même temps et donc si un
certain nombre de pays qui sont d'accord
pour avancer sur le des économies
d'énergie ou sur le plan de la
transition énergétique globalement et
bien qu'il se mette en commun pour
avancer et ensuite les autres peut-être
suivront si on ne fait pas ça le
sentiment que nous n'y arriverons pas
deuxième point que vous avez évoqué qui
est aussi très important c'est la
croissance qui selon moi malheureusement
risque d'être durablement faible
contrairement à ce qu'on peut imaginer
vous l'avez souligné je partage ce point
de vue le président actuel le président
précédent et c'est le risque majeur
pour notre pays et notamment dans le
cadre de cette loi de transition
énergétique et donc si nos raisonnements
si nous raisonnons pardon dans le cadre
d'une croissance durablement faible ça
pose bien entendu le problème des moyens
ensuite et le discours que nous avons si
nous n'avons pas les moyens à mettre en
face ça sert à rien de discourir parce
que le décalage qui existe aujourd'hui
entre le discours politique et la
perception que peut en avoir l'opinion
serait à nouveau
élargi donc je crois que c'est une
question c'est un problème semble-t-il
important et du coup j'en viens
un second sujet que vous avez évoqué et
développé en particulier madame Mezard
celui de la précarité énergétique le
dernier rapport de l'Unicef sur la
pauvreté des enfants et catastrophique
pour notre pays catastrophique ceux qui
souffrent le plus aujourd'hui de la
pauvreté ce sont les enfants ici
également l'hérédité de la pauvreté qui
est du coup mis en avant et nous savons
que ce sont les ménages en grande
difficulté qui les premiers font des
efforts au niveau de leur chauffage en
hiver et nous allons nous allons y
arriver du coup si le chèque est énergie
est important si le fait d'avoir
interdit de couper
l'électricité en période hivernale les
tout autant c'est incontestablement
nécessaire je ne suis pas persuadé que
ce soit suffisant il faut aller plus
loin et vous l'avez souligné dans le
cadre des économies d'énergie des
travaux à réaliser dans les bâtiments ce
sont les familles en situation une
pauvreté et d'extrême pauvreté qui en
souffrent le plus bien entendu des
bâtiments énergivores je pense que sur
cette question de précarité énergétique
ça doit être je dirais très mise en
avant pour que c'est population qui se
sentent à côté de notre vie démocratique
plus être incluse dans notre vie
démocratique de manière à crédibiliser
aussi cet aspect de transition
énergétique indispensable pour
nous-mêmes mais pour les générations
futures dernier point deux trois points
sur la recherche oui 10 fois 100 fois
oui la recherche en refusant toute
obscurantisme en ayant des interventions
et des propos
frappés au coin du bon sens et rationnel
quel que soit la recherche effectuée
nous ne devons pas par principe ça
existe parfois considérer qu'elle ne
doit pas exister elle doit exister se
mettre en oeuvre ensuite c'est à nous
d'appréhender responsable politique les
tenants et les aboutissants des
découvertes mais la refusé par principe
me semble extrêmement dangereux
merci Monsieur Pointreau
oui merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de faire bref sur le
4 points sur la transition énergétique
concernant les transports c'est vrai que
il y a beaucoup de contradictions
beaucoup d'incohérences et ça a été dit
tout à l'heure avec l'abandon de
l'écotaxe notamment et
sur le fait qu'on s'aperçoit que on a de
plus en plus de camions sur les routes
sur les autoroutes et on n'a pas entendu
parler ce matin du fer outrage du frais
de ferroviaire où il y a on voit bien
que la SNCF ne fait pas tout ce qu'il
faut pour
avancer sur ce sujet
je sais pas si c'est le rôle de la SNCF
de faire du covoiturage de réaliser le
covoiturage ou de faire du transport
routier mais il faudrait qu'elle
s'intéresse un peu plus à son métier de
de base deuxième point quel est le poids
de la France dans notre volonté de
transition
énergétique
c'est bien beau de vouloir toujours
toujours montrer l'exemple d'être le
mieux 10 ans sur le sur le plan
écologique
mais il faut savoir est-ce que ça va pas
être au détriment de la compétitivité
puisque on voit bien qu'on n'a pas on
l'a dit on n'a pas de politique
européenne énergétique on a pas de
politique européenne sociale et que
c'est vu par les entreprises par le
monde agricole comme une une punition on
voit bien ça a été dit c'est plus vu
comme une punition parce que il y a
beaucoup il y a pas de retour à
l'investissement qui est avéré quand on
fait le calcul au départ il y a pas un
retour à l'investissement il y a plus de
charges que de retour à l'investissement
et il faudrait expliquer et faire de la
pédagogie peut-être à nos entreprises et
puis le dernier point je par rapport là
je m'adresse à Monsieur Je vous aime par
rapport à ce nouveau rapport qui
inquiétant et anxiogène sur le le climat
je voudrais savoir ce que pense monsieur
Jouzel de la dernière étude concernant
le professeur Robert stavins de
l'Université de Harvard qui précise que
la température s'est stabilisée dans la
basse stratosphère depuis maintenant
deux décennies et par rapport aussi à ce
qu'on peut entendre un peu sahela que la
couche de zone s'améliore et que voilà
donc il y a des contradictions aussi
dans les études moi j'aimerais bien
avoir quelques
points sur ce sujet
la parole est à Martial Bourquin
oui Michel le Président je voudrais
remercier les intervenants
on a eu une belle franchement une de
belles interventions qui nous permet de
d'apprécier le spectre des problèmes de
la transition énergétique
mon souci c'est que nous vivons
ralentissement économique important
comme l'a dit le président
tout à l'heure et
certains risquent de faire marche
arrière
allant chercher des marchés et mettant
de côté la transition énergétique c'est
le plus gros problème que nous pouvons
rencontrer et
je pense qu'il y a peut-être plusieurs
pistes mais que vous avez abordé mais je
voudrais préciser sur la fiscalité par
exemple on risque d'avoir un catalogue
de bonnes intentions
et ne pas avoir les moyens de les mettre
en œuvre
et si on n'a pas une action forte au
niveau de l'orientation de la fiscalité
certains pays d'Europe du Nord ont
basculé massivement la fiscalité du
travail vers la consommation de CO2
est-ce que ce n'est pas la piste à
privilégier et nous aurions là la
possibilité à la fois de faire baisser
le coût du travail on sait que
aujourd'hui c'est un élément non
négligeable de compétitivité mais
deuxième chose d'intéresser fiscalement
à la transition énergétique et là ça
pourrait être une piste la deuxième
piste ce sont les appels d'offres
faire en sorte que sur les appels
d'offres l'empreinte carbone soit
beaucoup plus présente pour que
lorsqu'il y a comment confrontation de
prix
l'empreinte carbone soit un élément
déterminant de choix et là peut-être
faut-il travailler encore plus dans ce
domaine pour faire en sorte que les
entreprises en général mais aussi la
commande publique est énorme dans un
pays comme la France puisse travailler
faire en sorte que ce soit des non
seulement des ressources fiscales mais
on prenne le mieux disant énergétique et
au niveau de l'empreinte carbone voilà
je pense que pour les les plus les plus
fragiles d'entre nous
il y a une vraie question
on risque d'avoir
les bobos on risque d'avoir des
personnes qui ont les moyens qui vont
avoir des maisons passives et toute une
série de la population 8 à 10 millions
de personnes en France qui vont rester à
côté de cette transition énergétique et
je me demande où il y a par exemple de
la rue on va avoir tout à l'heure une
audition sur la rue on arrive à isoler
on arrive à faire en sorte qu'on est
vraiment une qualité
d'isolation bien meilleure mais on
laisse de côté des des millions de
personnes et ne faut-il pas avoir un
plan extrêmement
comment
audacieux de rénovation des immeubles
parce que maintenant dans certains
immeubles le prix des charges sont plus
importants que le prix des loyers
ça coûte très cher et en plus au niveau
de l'empreinte carbone c'est
catastrophique et là est-ce qu'on
devrait pas mettre en place ce plan
alors il y a un plan comme ça mais s'il
n'est pas les organismes HLM parfois ont
leurs difficultés intrinsèques si il n'y
a pas des aides importantes et si on ne
retrouve pas une fiscalité qui comment
pénalise comment la consommation
d'énergie va nous n'arriverons pas à
mettre en place ce plan voilà
monsieur le Président en tout cas on
vous remercie parce que c'est vous nous
avez fait des interventions avec vos
deux rapporteurs de grande qualité
bien merci je ne parle à Monsieur
Foucher il y aura après encore deux
intervenants de la commission du
développement durable et voilà et on
sera obligé vraiment de s'arrêter là
donc monsieur Foucher monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup simplement vous
évoquer monsieur le Président que tout
très forme parfois peut apparaître
négative mais tout ça dépend comme elle
est mise en place là je pose une
question sur des choses qui se passent
pratiquement sur le terrain et qu'on a
l'habitude de voir des uns et les autres
en tant qu'a élu et il y a deux sujets
que je constate c'est la politique
d'implantation en matière d'éolienne et
la politique qui concerne le
photovolvevoltaïque je crois pas que les
choses soient faites d'une manière très
cohérente et en matière d'éolien des
marcheurs permanent de groupe auprès des
communes et d'intercommunalité pour
l'implantation de sur éolien on tient
pas compte des paysages on tient compte
uniquement des incitations financières
donc je dis tout ça n'est pas fait d'une
manière sérieuse et je crois que le
l'État dans ce domaine laisse faire les
choses d'une manière beaucoup trop
souple et je pense qu'il faudrait une
mise en place d'une politique cohérente
et sérieuse et en matière de
photovoltaïque souvenez-vous il y a eu
un frein il y a quelques quelques années
au Sénat il y a eu un débat sur ce point
les choses sont reparties les bâtiments
sont repartis on reconstruit on
construit des bâtiments qui sont parfois
vides ou souvent vides uniquement pour
toucher un certain nombre de recettes
alors je veux dire il faudrait gérer à
la fois l'utile et l'efficace est-ce que
la transition doit pas être organisée
d'une manière intelligente et pas
totalement désordonnée comme elle est
aujourd'hui uniquement pour avoir des
pour avoir pour toucher de l'argent et
pas tenir compte en fait de la vraie
réalité
alors Joël l'abbé
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
désolé d'être arrivé en retard et c'est
par la voix de Roland Courtot que j'ai
entendu dire que le président de le voit
a parlé enthousiasme ça ne me surprend
pas en ayant connu comme président des
maires de France dans une autre vie en
tout cas l'enthousiasme effectivement
doit être là et l'enthousiasme derrière
un projet qui soit le qui soit le plus
lisible possible qui doit être lisible
nos jeunes générations ont actuellement
un énorme déficit de projet se dire 2050
on ne sait pas ce que sera la France on
ne sait pas ce que sera la planète il y
a un moment où pour des jeunes c'est
absolument inondable alors
l'enthousiasme nous on doit le
transmettre mais on doit le transmettre
derrière un projet alors ça c'est des
mots le projet évidemment alors
l'histoire de la croissance qui qui
traîne à venir la croissance du passé
sur les sur les critères du passé enfin
moi je suis plus que convaincu qu'elle
n'arrivera pas une nouvelle forme de
croissance avec une véritable la
transition non pas une rupture brusque
mais par contre une transition avec un
virage qui soit clairement donné avec
des orientations qui soient clairement
donné on a beaucoup beaucoup de domaines
où l'innovation est en place et au là on
a croisé de nouvelles formes d'emploi je
pense à l'économie sur circulaire la
transition énergétique évidemment
l'économique de proximité avec les
services à la personne l'économie
sociale et solidaire une nouvelle
économie agricole et alimentaire la
extrêmement pourvoyeuse en nouveaux
emplois qui sont des anciens d'anciens
emploi qui ont été éliminés dans une
nouvelle forme d'agriculture et
d'alimentation qui soit progressiste
mais là il faut qu'on ait une lecture
véritablement claire alors il y a des
antagonistes avec des lobbys avec tout
ça on peut pas avancer on a besoin
d'avoir quelque chose de clair et cette
transition qui a la véritable transition
de l'économie verte au sens large et
extrêmement noble du terme il y a
beaucoup à espérer là-dessus ceux qui
croient dans la recherche j'en fais
partie mais par contre pas à la
recherche qui soit une fuite en avant
celle des apprentis sorciers poussant à
la fuite en avant justement donc une
nouvelle société émergente elle est en
train de se construire presque en
souterrain d'une façon d'une façon
alternative mais extrêmement minoritaire
je vous invite à regarder je crois que
c'était le c'était hier soir le film de
Marie le nouveau film de Marie Monique
Robin sacré croissance regardez ça sur
l'ensemble de la planète les
alternatives émergentes qui sont qui
sont présentées et enfin je vais une
nouvelle fois citer Pierre Rabhi on y
arrivera lorsqu'on sera capable
d'admettre une sobriété heureuse je vous
remercie merci Madame Jouanneau
merci monsieur le Président un grand
merci à nos intervenants pour leur
capacité à mettre les points sur les i
et je pense qu'ils le font encore dans
leur réponse
premièrement il faudrait qu'on ait un
débat sur la l'adaptation et notamment à
la suite et du rapport que vous avez
fait au Conseil économique et social et
du rapport que Jean-Joseph a remis à la
ministre au mois de septembre
deuxièmement est-ce qu'il y a eu des
débats au sein de votre institution sur
les investissements nécessaires
effectivement pour cette transition y
compris la question des subventions ou
dépenses fiscales en faveur des énergies
fossiles versus le coût que
représenterait l'inaction troisièmement
est-ce que vous avez eu des débats sur
les objectifs en termes de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ou
d'empreintes carbone
parce que la situation de la France
n'est pas nécessairement brillante sur
sur ce point quatrièmement est-ce que
quels ont été les débats autour du
principe d'expérimentation alors là je
pense à l'économie circulaire puisque on
voit que les projets d'écologie
industrielle territoriaux patine faute
de liberté d'expérimentation locale et
cinquièmement j'ai vu des propos assez
positifs sur les questions de
fabrication additive est-ce que vous
envisagez un rapport sur ce sujet est-ce
que vous en avez envisagez un rapport
sur la société ou l'économie
collaborative merci
alors dernière intervenant pour les
affaires d'économiques d'Ali Grémillet
oui merci président très brièvement
effectivement je partage complètement
l'expression de dire ce rapport doit
bien se placer dans un contexte de
transition énergétique et je pense qu'il
serait peut-être judicieux comme
d'autres collègues l'ont dit tout à
l'heure
que le CSS nous apporte aussi des
éclairages parce que là on est sur
l'énergie la transition énergétique
on a d'autres défis dans notre pays
celui de l'emploi je suis de la
reconquête industrielle et il serait
judicieux de faire des croisements entre
les réflexions et les rapports et
notamment les rapports qui ont été faits
au niveau de la commission économique
du CEC sur
ses orientations ces stratégies de
reconquête industrielle on sait tous en
termes industriel que il y a deux
emplois deux raisons de la compétitivité
la première c'est bien sûr le coût de la
main d'oeuvre mais pour toutes les
entreprises ou on prépare nos budgets
aujourd'hui
un des points clés c'est le prix
énergétique et aujourd'hui le monde
industriel notre pays est en assiste à
un renouvellement assez profond des
systèmes énergétiques
on voit que le nucléaire apporte une
stabilité
à la compétitivité à apporter une ligne
directrice au monde industriel c'est de
savoir comment on peut imaginer la
transition énergétique avec le mariage
et c'est obligation de reconquérir et de
redéployer notre industrie de production
dans notre pays par rapport aux besoins
énergétiques et je termine mon propos
sur effectivement on parle beaucoup de
recherches mais la véritable recherche
c'est celle qui s'applique c'est celle
qui se développe dans les entreprises
donc je fais une distinction entre la
recherche et la recherche appliquée
et c'est essentiel et je prends
l'exemple concret je suis dans un
département où il y a beaucoup de bois
on a assisté à de nouvelles
connaissances sur la biomasse
conséquence le monde industriel dans ma
région a fait beaucoup de reconversion
énergétique sur la biomasse et
aujourd'hui les feux se mettent au rouge
en disant attention attention pas si
vite est-ce que nous aurons la capacité
à produire effectivement la matière
nécessaire à l'alimentation énergétique
de cette nouvelle forme de transition
énergétique quelque part donc c'est le
mariage des trois la capacité de
production le mariage de la nécessité
industrielle sur la reconquête au niveau
de la France de ses capitaux dans un
concert enfin de transition énergétique
merci dernière question sur Paul Vergès
j'ai écouté avec passion
tous les exposés et également avec
angoisse en pensant à l'avenir
et vous avez insisté sur l'aspect
national l'importance nationale notre
attention européenne et l'importance
mondiale
or la Réunion est un département intégré
à la France
intégré à l'Europe mais nous sommes dans
l'océan Indien à 10000 km
et nous sommes face à une situation
totalement différente
et sur ce plan
nous avons tous les éléments pour la
transition énergétique
nous avons l'éolien les alizés nous
avons le soleil
nous avons l'hydraulique nous sommes un
pays montagneux nous avons la géothermie
avec un volcan en activité et nous avons
l'océan
et le problème c'est comment faire cette
transition démographique puisque la
Réunion est un laboratoire
de tout ce qu'il fallait pas faire
je vous donne un seul exemple
la facture du pétrole et du charbon
augmente chaque année chez nous
et le nombre de voitures et l'élément le
plus important de notre économie
premièrement deuxièmement sur le plan
global nous sommes dans une zone de
l'ancien empire colonial français
Maurice les Seychelles les Comores
Madagascar des colonies françaises or
nous sommes dans une situation
d'évolution considérable
et qui pose le problème de l'énergie
sous l'angle de la pression
démographique je vous donne un seul
exemple nous étions 230 000 habitants en
1946 4 un ennemi un département nous
sommes actuellement 850
000 et nous allons être un million d'un
quinze
mais
c'est une ligne modeste mais nous avons
toutes les îles minuscules
des Seychelles les Maldives
Maurice plus importantes les Comores
nous avons également une immense qui est
malgré ce
4 millions d'habitants en 46 c'est 24
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui et en
2050 c'est 55 millions d'habitants
ça veut dire que nous ne pourrons pas
poser le problème de l'énergie la
transition énergétique simplement sous
l'angle de la Réunion
comment allons-nous faire
sur avec le voisinage d'une île comme
Madagascar
la Réunion est la distance c'est 700 km
c'est Paris Marseille
et nous allons voir
un pays de 55 millions d'habitants en
pays grand comme la France la Belgique
et la Hollande réunis avec des richesses
intactes et toutes les transformations
qui ont changé
avec la politique et encouragée par
l'Union européenne de regroupement des
pays d'Afrique de la zone orientale
d'Afrique
en décembre dans quelques semaines va
être signé l'accord d'intégration de
tous ces pays depuis l'Afrique du Sud
jusqu'au nord perspective 600 millions
d'habitants
allons nous faire
dans les années qui viennent
un département intégré à la France et à
l'Europe où l'Europe nous dit intégrez
vous à ce nouvel espace de 600 millions
d'habitants
comment
concilier tous ces problèmes voilà
l'importance que nous avons c'est
pourquoi nous sommes intéressés à la
fois par ce débat national de
l'intégration Europe comme nous sommes
passionnés par le débat sur la
conférence de Paris en décembre 2015
toutes ces îles de l'ancienne empire
coloniale française avec les Maldives
sont
intégré dans une institution la
commission
nous couvrons un espace maritime commun
qui est égal à la Méditerranée
et on entend tout le temps dire la
France et le deuxième puissance maritime
du monde et tout et nous avons là une
demande de toutes ces populations de
co-développement
à des états différents de développement
voilà le problème angoissants qui se
posent à nous parce que c'est la zone de
révolution dans tous les domaines
climatique démographique et tout comment
faire face c'est pour ça que je vous
disais je vous suis avec passion mais
également avec angoisse merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président on va donner la
parole tout de suite au présent de nos
voix et au rapporteur pour répondre à
ces questions
je veux rester quand même mais bon
c'est pas bien donc oui sur le rapport
Harvard d'où effectivement il y a un
lien entre entre la température
stratosphère donc c'est l'autre
atmosphère et
l'ozone enfin bon par contre le trou
d'ozone n'a pas le lien direct
complètement avec le problème de
réchauffement climatique ce qui est
important de retenir dans ce contexte
des températures c'est effectivement que
les qu'ils ont pour nous le
réchauffement est sans équivoque il y a
beaucoup d'indications
bon alors ça c'est un peu anecdotique
mais il y a quand même toutes les
chances que 2014 soit l'année la plus
chaude qu'on n'a jamais connu alors sur
c'est lié parce que température sera
tous faite on peut se faire on attend
effectivement ce que la stratosphère
décroise quand les températures
stratosphère décroisses quand les
températures de l'atmosphère de ils ont
de la basse atmosphère croise les
DOM-TOM oui c'est important j'étais
effectivement j'ai passé la soirée hier
au mardi de la semaine transition
énergétique et DOM-TOM donc voilà
j'étais
que je suis allé au citoyen j'ai
beaucoup écouté donc c'était plus un son
national mais il y a un vrai souci il
faut prendre ça en compte et c'est très
très important je sais la situation de
la Réunion en particulier des points
importants c'est vrai pour le faire
routage
disons
l'idée de de contribution cubaine
énergie de sur le transport était lié au
développement du fer outrage donc c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas non plus reprocher
c'est ça le problème c'est que en fait
il y a un volley qui qui était
intéressant mais c'était aussi de
problèmes de faire routagement
économique je vais simplement dire je
terminerai là que aussi bien au niveau
français donc il y a aussi des
estimations dans dans le débat sur la
transition énergétique qu'au niveau
mondial
à moyen terme c'est gagnant il faut
surtout pas penser à moyen terme à 10-15
ans c'est une vision politique c'est
tout ce qu'on demande aux comment est-ce
que je demande à mes politiques c'est
vraiment une vision à long terme
échec Jean-Paul de le voir sera d'accord
c'est ça qu'il nous faut et là il s'agit
simplement d'une vision à long terme si
vous regardez l'an prochain il y aura
des changements d'emploi et y compris au
16 heures on discute beaucoup il y a des
syndicats sont représentés ils sont très
conscients qui va avoir des pertes
d'emploi dans certains domaines des
gains d'emploi dans d'autres mais il
faut faire cette transition énergétique
oui avec cette idée effectivement que le
monde bouge et s'il bouge pas si bouge
pas ici va bouger sans nous c'est bien
ça qu'il faut voir
bien Laurence juste alors deux petits
mots les territoires à énergie positives
attention à la façon dont on comprend
bien cette idée là qui est une bonne
idée mais qu'il faut mettre en relation
avec le fait que ça veut dire un bilan
consommation production d'électricité
qui tiennent la route on voit bien que
il faut arriver à marier des
expérimentations mais tout en ayant bien
en tête que la solidarité qui est la
base du système électrique français doit
se poursuivre y compris pour les
territoires qui développent des idées de
bilan énergétiques positive mais il y a
des expériences qu'on a suivies montrent
que ils n'ont pas de moyens de
production donc il dépendent d'une
production qui est ailleurs il y a des
endroits en France où il y a aucun outil
de production d'électricité et
heureusement tout le système des
infrastructures a été organisée sur la
solidarité et sur la péréquation
tarifaire donc c'est des petits mots qui
nous paraissent un peu ringard aux uns
et aux autres enfin aux jeunes mais
qu'il faut quand même se rappeler
donc voilà j'irai pas plus loin donc
dans notre avis on a abordé avec
beaucoup de prudence cette idée là en
disant qu'il fallait vraiment regarder
ce qui se faisait mais toujours la
mettre en perspective de l'équilibre
globale du système qui doit permettre à
tout Français ou qu'il soit d'avoir
accès à l'énergie à l'électricité voilà
la fiscalité bon je vais pas répondre
précisément mais toutes les idées qui
ont été émises me semble de nature à
être intéressant donc il faut les
examiner et il y aura vraiment une enfin
un choix une priorisation ou une
cohérence à faire entre le remboursement
de la dette à travers la fiscalité
aujourd'hui et les mesures incitatives
sur un secteur alors est-ce la
transition énergétique est-ce un autre
secteur je pense que les travaux au
départ le long terme
de hi maîtriser et de donner une vraie
cohérence à un système fiscal qui
peut-être n'est pas totalement lisible
pour tout le monde alors et puis un
dernier point mais qui me semble
important parce que les expérimentations
en économie circulaire il y en a mais
j'ai travaillé un peu dessus à
l'occasion de mon
précédent ma précédente responsabilité
ce qui fait que sa réussite c'est la
qualité du leader on a dans l'Est Daniel
grimmiel connaît bien un homme qui a
mené un combat de 10 ans pour arriver à
mettre en place un système de
méthanisation qui permettent de produire
du biométhane carburant du biométhane
mis dans le réseau etc ça a été dix ans
bataille 10 ans alors sur la
réglementation de la pédagogie mobilisée
etc
donc aujourd'hui il faut qu'on ait des
leaders comme ça qui sont capables de
nous faire tous bouger moi qui était à
l'époque quand il a commencé
son projet à Gaz de France nous n'étions
pas encore GDF Suez on était tous inséré
à Gaz de France sur ce genre de choses
donc avec des hommes comme ça qui ont un
vrai projet local qui a du sens qui crée
de la riche locale et bien oui il faut
des gens comme ça pour arriver à mener
du terrain des projets et la
réglementation elle a suivi derrière il
a fallu aussi qu'il se battent avec
l'administration et puis maintenant vous
savez que GrDF est aujourd'hui encore
continue à être très engagés sur tous
ces projets de de méthanisation
la fabrique alors les expérimentations
il en faut ça c'est évident et voilà bon
et la fabrication additive on a un
rapport qui est en train de se
travailler au 16e parce que moi j'ai
découvert au sujet de la récemment grâce
à ce travail que nous faisons et pour
moi il y a vraiment là une mine pour
l'avenir extrêmement intéressante qui va
révolutionner les process de production
les compétences les emplois enfin je
pense que vraiment enfin je suis moi
dans l'étonnement de ce qui ce qui nous
attend Jean n'a pas dit que nous avions
eu une recommandation sur le plan
pluriannuel emploi et ce qui me semble
intéressant de vous dire en quelques
mots c'est qu'il a fait l'adhésion de
tout le monde ou ses oeuvres et donc
c'est une mesure qui est vraiment
à mon avis
utile d'avoir en tête parce que il y a
une mobilisation que ce soit des
syndicats le monde de l'entreprise les
associations enfin tout le monde était
d'accord pour travailler sur cette
notion d'implant plus réel de l'emploi
voilà je m'arrête là on a bien merci
Laurent monsieur le Président simplement
quelques mots de
conclusion merci
l'ensemble des parlementaire je vous
rappelle monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président que vous avez la faculté
aujourd'hui par la révision
constitutionnelle de demander à votre
président de pouvoir saisir le ses œufs
sur un centre de travaux dont vous
estimeriez éventuellement nécessaire
pour améliorer ou vous aider à la
décision politique nous serions
extrêmement sensibles à la capacité
Corée le Sénat de pouvoir de saisir
deuxième élément permettez-moi
simplement j'espère que vous pardonnez à
l'avance peut-être de mon impertinence
de vous dire à quel point dans l'état de
l'actuel où se trouve la société d'être
extrêmement attentif est-ce que vous
n'ayez pas un discours plein d'illusions
et de rêve l'objectif est bien
l'atteindre c'est mieux et le faire agir
est extrêmement important
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
tout sur la table et politique avec la
restauration et la noblesse du politique
tout est détruit par les attitudes
politiciennes et je pense que si vous
arrivez à faire en sorte que la cause de
l'énergie
transcende les intérêts énergiques c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait fondamental
et je vous donne deux ou trois exemples
premier exemple je crois qui ne serait
pas anodin que vous essayez peut-être
d'entendre le secrétaire général aux
Affaires européennes pour voir dans la
négociations européennes quels sont les
clivages compliqués on a pu obtenir un
accord sur le changement climatique
parce que l'Espagne et le Portugal avait
demandé la connexion avec la France mais
la problème polonais est un peu
compliqué il faudrait essayer de cerner
quels sont les freins à l'évidence que
disait madame lézard les capitaux
s'investissent beaucoup sur les outils
de production parce qu'il y a une
rotation rapide beaucoup moins dans les
infrastructures de transport car il y a
une radio sur Nantes or le demain le
problème ça va être non seulement la
production mais la régulation et la
capacité par l'intelligence numérique de
pouvoir réguler les zones de production
qui peuvent varier selon les climats et
l'expérience allemande est en train de
nous montrer à quel point il peut y
avoir un syndrome de freins ou
d'interrogations sur lequel cette vision
européenne se modèle énergétique
européen cette solidarité infra-étatique
européenne est un élément extrêmement
lourd troisième élément nous avons très
clairement indiqué que sur la recherche
et le développement il y avait une
réflexion à mener sur l'augmentation du
prix du carbone par sur le marché
carbone et une captation d'une partie de
ces flux financiers pour pouvoir
alimenter la recherche et le
développement je rappelle que la moitié
des chercheurs dans le monde sont
américains et chinois que la France est
très bonne en recherche fondamentale
très peu en recherche appliquées nous
sommes en train dans une économie de
l'innovation de perdre la bataille de la
recherche et nous n'y prenons paga or
l'énergie est un facteur de mobilisation
industrielle de mobilisation d'un mode
de société et d'une mobilisation
citoyenne donc au lieu de voir cela
comme une contrainte parce qu'il y a une
punition
de plus de degrés si jamais nous ne
prenons pas essayons au contraire de
transformer cette contrainte en
objective mobilisateur pour renforcer
notre business de recherche les chinois
sont en train de faire des choses
absolument extraordinaires mais ils sont
en train de s'engager dans une politique
environnementale parce que derrière il y
a un business avec un retour
d'investissement et dans ce retour
d'investissement j'étais retraite
attention sur un certain nombre de frein
ce que disait madame esard c'est que
l'ensemble des acteurs du conseil
économique social environnemental à
estimer que la problématique de la
rénovation thermique n'était pas
uniquement peut-être un problème
budgétaire mais un problème de faiblesse
de moyens d'ingénierie auprès des
artisans auprès des emplois qui ne sont
pas suffisamment formés il s'agit pas
d'ouvrir un marché le marché existe mais
quelle est la bonne réponse or un
certain nombre de d'enquêtes qui ont été
menées ont montré aujourd'hui le besoin
peut-être d'une mobilisation forte du
monde artisanal par ce marché-là mais
avec une formation des artisans de
nouvelles techniques par une formation
des conseils à apporter sur les
meilleurs choix et les une réponse à la
rénovation thermique et comme vous
l'indiquait nous avons demandé aussi
est-ce que les collectivités
territoriales puissent être des tiers
payants alors balayant l'argument que
nous était opposés par les banques
consistant que c'était un facteur de
concurrence voilà pour cette audition
des commissions des affaires économiques
et du développement durable ils ont donc
auditionné des membres du Conseil
économique social et environnemental
notamment Jean-Paul Delevoye le
président ainsi que Jean jauzal
également climatologue et vice-président
du GIEC sur et bien la transition
énergétique cela dans un contexte où on
sait que le réchauffement climatique est
alarmant notamment après la remise du
cinquième rapport du Gex groupe
d'experts intergouvernementaux sur le
climat rapport qui a donc été remis
dimanche dernier vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site public sénat.fr prochain
rendez-vous de l'actualité parlementaire
à 16h30 pour l'audition de François
Rebsamen le ministre du Travail qui va
être entendu par la commission des
affaires sociales sur la formation
professionnelle cela dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances pour 2015 très
bonne fin de journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires